and II I don't know if you I wanted to
bring up something I know you're a
documentary fanatic he loves his
documentaries have you seen those
documentaries about the fire festival
yeah I did I saw the one on Hulu yeah
yeah well for those of you who haven't
heard of it
fire fest was this luxury music festival
in the Bahamas that turned into a
massive disaster just couple years ago
remember this I do yeah I mean the
guests were promised like you know fancy
cabanas and gourmet meals and when they
got there it was like FEMA tents and
rubber mattresses and bad food and
backed up porta-potties it was was awful
yeah you should talk Andy okay who said
that
I'm sorry Conan Andy promised us a
once-in-a-lifetime luxury Conan taping
experience and he lied we want our money
back it's a ripoff well you're not
getting your money back
oh wait wait wait and wait a minute wait
a minute man wait a minute
what do you mean money back it's it's a
free taping not for us
Andy charge us $5,000 apiece from
once-in-a-lifetime luxury taping he
promised us VIP seats these are not VIP
themes they sure are hon VIP visually
inferior perspective read the fine print
dummy what about the plane ride and the
unlimited champagne and the caviar Andy
you just can't promise stuff like that
listen I gave those rubes everything I
promised yeah
this isn't champagne it's apple juice
with an alka-seltzer tablet yeah well in
Illinois that's what we called champagne
sorry I grew up poor mrs. got rocks
what about the plane ride what do you
think I gave you when you came to the
studio we even have a picture of it
that's called a plane ride ask my kids
tonin he promises caviar I looked it up
real caviar doesn't come out of a trout
I mean watch this
I mean it's delicious but it's not
caviar trout eggs that's disgusting and
he just give them their $15,000 back
listen I can't between marketing and
advertising I'm 30 grand in the hole at
pregnant trout cost me 10 grand oh wait
a minute
you spent more money than you could ever
make you're an idiot Andy yeah I'm an
idiot an idiot like a fox I just sold
the rights to Hulu they're making a
documentary coming soon idiot like a fox
how Andy Richter's scammed - the Conan
audience only on hulu hulu will buy
anything netflix passes on
you